Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of patience
of authored by
the 48th narration, the narration of
in which he narrates saying
[Silence]
Bkari.
Abu narrates that a man
said to the prophet Sam.
Advise me. This is a question that's
repeated often by the companions. We
have a number of narrations in which
people come to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam asking for advice.
However, the advice is always different.
The question is the same but the advice
is always different. Why is that?
Because the person asking the question
is different. And the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
is giving that person what they are most
in need of in order to secure their
success.
A doctor or a scholar that gives the
same answer to everyone is a doctor
that gives the same prescription to
everyone.
This religion
is medicine
and
this medicine is practiced by
professionals
by scholars of Islam
and they are the ones that give us
direction in this sea
this literal ocean
of knowledge.
this ocean of knowledge that is the
Quran and Sunnah. They are the ones that
have sailed those seas for many years.
They know them. And so when they give us
directions, we have to take their
directions. One of the most dangerous
things is for a person to just jump head
headlong into any random book that he
finds, any random narration that he
finds, any random subject or topic that
he finds.
This is not how knowledge is sought.
And this is very dangerous. Just if
a person were to get the keys to the
pharmacy and walk into the pharmacy and
start pulling off of the shelf random
medicines, whatever looks good, whatever
has a nice box or this one has a nice
picture on it or I the color scheme
of this bottle and just starts
swallowing pills. Person will most
likely poison himself.
[Arabic recitation]
he tells us that ignorance is a deadly
illness
and its cure is found in two things. Two
things together when they come together.
This is where we get the cure to the
illness that is ignorance.
A statement,
a
a verse, a narration of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, a verse of the
Quran. That's only one part of it. What
is the other part of it? He tells us the
other part of it is
and the doctor that gives this
prescription is the strong
cultivating scholar. This is who gives
it. We don't just jump into the
pharmacy. There's a reason we have laws
that stop people from doing that.
Medicine is only medicine for the right
sickness, right? And so this is why the
scholars of Islam
even with their students, you don't just
start with Bkari, pick up Bkari. Well,
everything in it is authentic. This is
the best book, you know, and the
scholars all agree on this. just pick it
up and start reading in any old place
and flip through its pages you're
flipping through a magazine. That's not
how knowledge works.
And that is not the way that a person
obtains knowledge. you must go to and go
through and by the
advice and direction of the scholars
of Islam.
He says that a man came and asked the
prophet sallall.aii
advise me
and he said
do not become angry.
I think every one of us here has heard
this narration before. Do not become
angry. So the man repeated himself. What
else? And asking for more. And at each
time he would ask, he would repeat, do
not become angry. Here's a question.
How is it possible to not become angry?
How is it? That's that's like
saying don't become afraid ever. Don't
ever get scared.
That's not something that I'm in control
of. That's a natural response that
people have. Some people are more scared
than others. You can try to learn some
kind of you know courage but the
human being will always get scared of
something just the human being will
always get upset or angry or the human
being will always feel comfortable at
something or feel uncomfortable with
something or one thing or dislike
another. And so when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam says do not
become angry. The scholars tell us that
this statement
[Silence]
love, dislike, anger, happiness.
These are things that the human being is
not in direct control of.
As
said that the prophet Sam
would be just in distribution amongst
his wives and then would make the dua,
"Oh Allah, this is what I am able to do.
So do not hold me to account for what I
am unable to do." meaning
be equal in his love for each and every
one of his life his wives. He loves some
of them more than others. This is
natural. He loves some of his companions
more than others.
This is the nature of the human being.
It's not something that you or I are in
direct control of, but we are in
indirect control of. And that's what the
narration is speaking about. for
[Silence]
he says the scholars tell us that this
narration holds two meanings. Number
one, do not become angry. Meaning, do
not do anything or be in a situation
that will make you angry.
So, as we said, we're not in direct
control of what makes us angry, but we
are in indirect control. Indirect
control meaning I know a particular
topic or a particular person or a
particular situation or a particular
environment. These are things that will
make me angry and I know that it usually
ends in anger. Therefore I am to avoid
these these things.
[Silence]
The second meaning is that if anger does
happen that you control yourself while
you are angry that you control yourself.
Becoming angry is not shameful
unfortunately because we have learned
the way the argument of the hypoc of the
hypocrites. We've learned to
pick at each other. If we see someone
gets upset, we say, "Oh, oh, don't get
upset. Why are you upset?" That is not
something that any of us is immune
from. And that in itself is not
shameful. The prophets, the messengers,
the messenger MS, the messenger Ibraim,
[Arabic recitation]
all become angry because they are human
beings and a human being has been given
many traits and one of those traits is
anger.
If you met someone that never became
angry for any reason,
any reason,
nothing made him angry.
Someone would
, you know, transgress against his
wife, his daughters, his mother,
wouldn't make him upset, wouldn't make
him angry. Would that be a person that
we would praise? Is that a praiseworthy
trait? Of course not. As a matter of
fact, there are
instances where not becoming angry
can be considered a sin.
For instance, at Die
when a person has no jealousy,
doesn't become angry when his wife or
his spouse is is you know
transgressed against in a sexual manner.
or someone who sexual makes sexual
advances towards his his wife or his
daughter or his mother. This is this
means something is seriously wrong with
this person. If they did not become
angry from something this
became angry so angry he threw the
tablets
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala had gave
him. What was he angry for? for the sake
of Allah because of because of the
worship of other than Allah. Therefore
Allah praised his anger in
because that is what a believer is. He
becomes angry for the anger of Allah
becomes pleased with the pleasure of
Allah. So this narration means two
things. is do not become angry. Meaning,
do not put yourself in a situation or on
a topic or with a person that will make
you angry. When you start to see those
road signs that you're going down that
direction, you stop way before you you
get to the point where you're angry. But
if you do become angry that you control
yourself
means these two things.
for
and
Allah Jesus.